une arrivée sur le mont royal au lever
du jour une image extraordinaire
embellie par l'accolade entre johann
roques et ses trois enfants après deux
semaines d'efforts surhumains et 1130 km
de course en sandales il a gagné son
pari
j'en ai fait pas mal de courses j'avais
jamais pleuré à la fin d'une course là
je savais que ça sent le sapin pour ces
dernières foulées l'ultramarathonien a
été rejoint par une vingtaine d'amis au
parc lafontaine
ensemble ils ont gravi le mont royal la
dernière d'une série d'épreuves victime
d'une infection à la jambe il a passé
une journée à l'hôpital dans god is love
avant de recevoir le feu vert pour
continuer tout entraîné autant que tu
veux tu peux pas tant traîné à une
infection bactérienne que une insolation
puis à tout ce qui va t'arriver encore
d'autres donc faut juste savoir
improviser trouvé le moyen d'avancer
quand même chaque jour johann roques a
couru entre 60 et 100 km plus d'une fois
il a songé à abandonner mais il s'est
accroché à un moment j'étais en boule
dans le coffre de la voiture donc celle
qui me servait de ravitaillement mobile
comme schiste est complètement démolie
mais je me dis je peux faire 5 km de
plus s'il parlait presque plus je me
laissais la fin il faisait noir
cette épouvantable hélas ici je vais y
aller
puis je les ai vus selvi sortir du
coffre bourré et couru les funk derniers
kilomètres au delà du défi physique et
mental
johann roques rentrer chez lui
émerveillé par la solidarité des gens
qu'il a croisés c'est ça qui m'a permis
de continuer tous les matins tous les
gens que j'ai rencontrés qui venait de
dormir dans une ferme laitière j'ai
dormi dans des chaleurs bord de fleuve
sans électricité je sais accueilli chez
du monde qui me nourrissais comme des
rois je m'étais juste ses pieds sous la
table on se coupe et deux mois comme
c'était complètement fou johann roques
ne sais pas quel sera son prochain grand
projet mais il publiera un livre en mars
pour raconter son oud c'est ce parcours
le long du saint laurent aura été tout
sauf un long fleuve tranquille
il sait antoine et radio canada montréal
c'est tout